the reaction to cop 26 and the glasgow
climate pact has of course been mixed
and while the deal was done the voices
who say it wasn't good enough for many
and varied but with a process which
needs consensus between nearly 200
countries is there any better way we'll
be discussing that in a moment first of
all though i want to bring in that
breaking news that we've had uh in the
last hour or so that nicholas sturgeon
first minister of scotland says that the
cambo oil field should not get the green
light we know that this is a change of
of heart um days perhaps i can get your
assessment on this first do you think
that cop 26 potentially could have
helped change nicola sturgeon's mind or
push her into this direction
yeah definitely i feel like i've seen
nicola surgeon's coverage she wasn't
just spending time in the blue zone but
she's spending time with indigenous
leaders with activists uh she was
spending time with the average person
who's tired of you know the fact that
we've declared a crime emergency for
many years but we're still looking to
drill for oil
which is highly contradictory so i'm
really happy and quite proud the fact
that we have our politicians really
saying okay now we need to take this
seriously and we're not going to be
commissioning projects that end up
causing environmental disaster yeah
baroness worthington we had that that
final deal of course uh at the weekend
but there are wider ramifications from
cop 26 potentially
yes um the the cop process has a lot of
catalytic effects um it passes
legislation which sends a very strong
signal that the world is now serious
about tackling this cut together all
countries agreeing and um it also
convenes a huge amount of people in the
side events that are there to discuss
what does the future look like and how
do we make real things happen in the
real economy so it definitely provides a
focus
and sets momentum off in the real
economy which is absolutely what's
needed we need to move faster and into
much more ambitious targets very quickly
yeah just staying with you baroness
there was a lot of criticism that it was
a very exclusive event but are you
saying that actually
a lot of important discussion was held
on the periphery
the nature of the talks are quite
exclusive in the sense that it's a very
bureaucratic process and it's almost you
could almost say it's deliberately
opaque um the naming terminologies the
way it's run it's not accessible
i worry that even member states actually
struggle to cover the complexity and all
of the side talks that go on that
constitute i mean 57 formal documents
were negotiated and published smaller
island states are going to struggle to
keep across all of that and so therefore
it kind of lends itself to an inside
track game and of course those people
who stand to lose from those
negotiations make sure that they're in
the room through whatever means they can
and there's been lots of reports about
how many fossil fuel lobbyists were
actually in that venue part of the
inside track which does feel quite
exclusionary at times yeah but dave
you're nodding along but there was a
huge amount of media there more than any
other cop civil society groups
indigenous communities young people etc
etc surely they all have an influence on
what's going on and help to make it more
transparent surely
i feel like they do have an influence
and even just the demands of them being
there and saying we're here we're taking
up space and holding you to account
however there is this limitation of when
you're not actually allowed into the
room how do you make sure that you're
like picking up on the smaller details
you know like we had um the the watering
down of the final agreement and one word
was was a real change of from phase out
phase down and these are things that the
average person and the general public if
they were there allowed to observe the
process allowed to fully get involved
we will see you know like there will be
like a level of accountability that i
think governments have not had within
processes okay so staying with you
days uh
you've put the issues and the problems
there but what is a better solution
isn't it's not perfect but is there
anything better
yeah it's not perfect but i think there
is a lot that we can work on this
process or even rebuilding this process
in its entirety because it doesn't work
for everyone um it doesn't even work for
the president a lock sharma who very
tearingly said that he's disappointed
and he apologized for the outcome of
this talk which says a lot um
historic achievement
yeah but then also um
would you like to go faster
he did say that didn't he he he
apologized for for the weakening of the
statement at the end but but afterwards
he did say it was historic
well this is almost a sign of how low
our expectations have been driven i'm
afraid 26 years of this have basically
meant that we're grateful for whatever
we get the success was it not blowing up
and it not you know being a complete
catastrophe so that if that's your bar
then yes it was a success but here you
could see in his eyes that he didn't
feel that he'd done his children's he
done the right thing by his children and
by all those people who were relying on
him to get a better deal and it's partly
just the function of how it's how it's
organized and how opaque it is and how
complex it is if it were a private
sector enterprise it would have been
reviewed streamlined and made much more
transparent and it just hasn't been and
i think that's it's no it's no one's
going to prioritize doing that but it
does need to be done for the sake of
everybody who's putting their hopes on
it yeah maybe there'll be improvements
in in 12 months time in egypt